hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be all about the houses of the
north and the North remembers story line
a lot of you guys have been asking me to
do a video about the northern Lords the
TV show it looks like it's bringing some
more of them on but there are a whole
bunch of houses there are a lot of
houses in the north and a lot of them
aren't ever gonna show up on the TV show
so what I'm gonna do is just a quick
rundown of all the houses of the north
where they're at and then I'm gonna
explain what the TV show might be doing
with some of them so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't watched season 5
of the TV show yet and new round of the
giveaway starts now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so here we go
starting with the 'greater houses we
have House Stark and house Bolton House
Stark obviously kind of scattered to the
four winds right now all across the
north Sansa and Rickon on the run Aria
in the east still in John Snow status
pending yes I have seen all the John
snows stuff all adds some links in the
description I've already done videos on
resurrection all the stuff I think is
gonna be happening with his character
but house Bolton now controls Winterfell
now they're also one of the bigger
lesser houses but technically they now
rule the North as of the end of season
five they successfully defended against
Stannis's invasion of Winterfell but
Roose Bolton is still trying to secure
the loyalty of the north but you have a
little finger kind of off to the side
that's slowly playing him against King's
Landing and playing King's Landing
against him so the North remembers they
hate the Bolton's and now King's Landing
is probably gonna hate the Bolton's to
that's to say nothing of the veil which
Littlefinger is also gonna try and use
against the Bolton's but that's like a
completely separate entity that's not
really part of the north moving down
south to moat Cailin typically that
would be a place that's controlled by
house read you know Howland Reed haven't
seen him on the show seen his kids quite
a bit but maybe they'll bring him on at
some point as the end of season fourth
the Bolton's had taken moat Cailin from
the Ironborn so presumably Howland Reed
is still running around the neck
somewhere TV show status currently
missing in action going back up to the
north we have the car starts in the car
hold as you remember during season three
Robb Stark executed the Lord of that
house Lord Karstark so they're not super
friendly with the Starks right now so if
any of the northern houses are not going
to remember then it's probably going to
be the Karstarks but also cut up near
this region as house umber now you
remember we saw a great John number on
the TV show they'll probably remember
because
great John number had a pretty good
relationship with Robb Stark and he was
not present at the twins during the red
wedding so he's one of those characters
with current status pending but there's
a character they cast for the TV show
that looks like it might be small John
umber
the other option being it could be
someone from house Manderley which is
down in white Harbor now they have a
really bad relationship with the Bolton
so I think they're definitely gonna
remember even if the TV show doesn't do
them they're one of the biggest houses
that the show hasn't done yet so I think
that they're big candidates for new
characters coming on the show moving
over to the west side of the north
another big location Deepwood Motte seat
of house Glover they really just show up
in the books but they're also
tangentially related to what's going on
in the telltale video game because they
also control ironrath which is the seat
of House Forrester I know everybody
wants to see the video game characters
show up on the TV show I don't think
it's ever gonna happen I don't think the
TV show is ever gonna reference what's
going on to the video game and even
though there's a bunch of other houses
in the books the one other big one that
I want to mention that might end up
showing up on the TV show is House Erwin
that's the closest castle to Winterfell
now they get tied up in Stannis's
plotline in the books if you remember he
is definitely still alive of the book so
regardless of what happens to him on the
show the books will continue with that
Stannis storyline but just because
there's such a big presence that close
to Winterfell I do think the TV show
will invoke them in some way or at least
reference them like the way we got the
reference to Bear Island and Lady Mormon
during season five before Stannis
marched on Winterfell he just asked some
of the northern Lords for support the
big joke was is that lady Mormont who is
like a really little girl she's like a
ten-year-old little girl told Stannis to
shove it the only lords of the north
that I recognized with the Starks so
fingers crossed that we actually get to
see her at some point but the show might
do that with some of the other lesser
houses that they don't want to cast just
like you know reference them as funny
jokes if you take from all over the
expanded Canon like the video games the
TV showed the books there's about 45
houses in the north that's how many
there are there's actually a lot of
people that the show is never gonna get
around to doing regardless of what you
think of the TV show and how it's
changed things from the books they've
done a pretty good job in season 5 of
foreshadowing what's gonna be going on
in and around the north during season 6
the North remembering that Bolton's are
status pending character
remembering that the Nights Watch are
and the Nights Watch in the
wildlings remembering that the White
Walkers are
lots of to go around in the
north I don't think
season six is gonna be a complete
revenge fantasy storyline a lot of good
people are still gonna die but but I do
think that we're due for a couple big
notable wins but let me know in the
comments
beyond the Nords trying to turn the
Bolton's into lunch what other big
battles do you want to see in the north
now I'm talking south of the wall
there's a hornet's nest of going on
down in King's Landing you have the
Martel's down further south and Dorne
you have the Tyrells the reach in old
town I mean there's a lot of stuff going
on all over Westeros and I don't want to
get into direct spoilers about what's
going on with a certain status pending
character there have been pictures of
him all over the set I feel like it was
more fun to talk about that right after
the season ended trying to catch HBO and
a lie like that the producers like oh we
know what's going on with this character
you guys can say whatever you want we
know what's really going on but but now
that it's kind of been turned into a
literal thing it's not quite as much fun
anymore it's like yeah yeah yeah more
evidence we already kind of knew what
was going on if you want to talk about
that though just please use spoiler tags
in the comments what about Sansa and
Rickon though Sansa and reek or on the
run Rick ends off with OSHA unless Sansa
runs into Brienne which I think is
somewhat unlikely I think that she'll
try to take in with one of the other
northern Lords that's loyal to the
Starks wreaking on the other hand unless
they do avast departure from his
storyline will show closer to the east
so he might show up with the umbers or
in white Harbor with the manderlys
whichever those northern Lords that the
show is gonna bring on I do think that
Santa is gonna stay with reek for most
of season six and because there's so
much Ironborn stuff going on it's
possible there could be some crossover
between Sansa storyline and the Ironborn
storyline but that remains to be seen
and it depends on how far Sansa and reek
go west I think what we'd really like to
see is a reverse red wedding on the
phrase and the Bolton's a lot of you
have been asking about trailers and such
just remember that promotional material
like that new video doesn't really drop
till the spring of each year so it's
gonna be a while before we see a Season
6 trailer we are getting pretty close to
the release of that Duncan egg book I
mean it's been released internationally
a couple places but as soon as it does
I'll totally give a couple copies away
while you guys wait for that you can
actually click here to learn all about
duncan egg and you can click here to
learn all about resurrection and the
Song of Ice and Fire I'll add some other
links in the description too thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you